Now because the tablet is at
the baseline density, its physical and
density independent pixel sizes
are the same, 1280 by 800.
This phone, on the other hand,
has a higher pixel density, so
it has half as many density
independent pixels as physical pixels.
So 400 by 640 density
independent pixels.
Now using density independent pixels
makes it easier to mentally picture,
that you have much more space on this
tablet than you do on this phone.
Similarly, if you have two devices
with similar screen sizes but
different pixel densities.
One is, let's say, 800 by 1280 pixels,
and the other is 400 by 640 pixels,
you might think that you have to
design totally different layouts for
the two of these devices.
However, when you think of the screens
in terms of density independent pixels,
they are the same size.
They are both 400 by 640 dps.
This makes it a lot easier
to make layout decisions.
You don't have to design
completely separate layouts.
You basically just design once, and
you'll kind of use the same layout
across both of these types of screens.